Mira en primer lugar, todas las cuestiones de Laufer
no pueden quedarse
simplemente en 1 1 reflexión personal,
tenemos que actuar
para mejorar la calidad democrática de nuestro país,
sobre todo porque además
el Presidente de gobierno y otras personas tienen
mucha capacidad para explicar lo que les,
lo que les ocurre,
pero hay muchos ciudadanos anónimos que sufren Laufer,
que no tienen esa capacidad
y que esperan de sus instituciones.
1 respuesta Clara,
que hay 2 cosas que tenemos pendientes
que no pueden esperar más.
La Primera es la reforma del
consejo general del poder judicial,
no podemos esperar más en afrontar esa cuestión.
Y la segunda, otra cuestión que el partido
socialista no ha querido afrontar
hasta ahora,
como es la derogación de la ley mordaza que llevamos
tanto tiempo de pidiendo
y tan tanto tiempo demandando y que está por hacer.
Por lo tanto, ese punto y aparte tiene que concretarse
cuando hablamos del aufer,
en medidas
muy concretas de mejora de la calidad democrática
de nuestro país.
La extrema derecha y sus tácticas
no las combatimos con discursos,
las combatimos con política.
Y hacer política significa
afrontar y ensanchar
el perímetro de los derechos de la ciudadanía
en nuestro país,
pues nosotros lo que queremos es afrontar la vivienda,
afrontar la fiscalidad,
afrontar la reducción de la jornada
y eso es lo que esperamos a partir de ahora.
También del Presidente del gobierno.
Necesitamos concreción.
Vamos a hacer ese punto y aparte,
pero vamos a afrontarlo en Serio,
desde sumar lo tenemos clarísimo